cédric du but qu'il est avocat
spécialiste des nouvelles technologies
bonjour merci à d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors son rachat
passe toujours aussi mal auprès des ong
et des défenseurs de la vie privée
de quoi concrètement anti part c'est une
question qui est simple dans qui est
excessivement complexes sont arrêtés il
ya deux niveaux de réflexion le premier
niveau c'est la position dominante de
google sur le marché des données et le
marché de la publicité publicité en
ligne tout simplement
donc google a déjà une situation quasi
monopolistique et elle va finalement
accroître sa position à la faveur de
cette acquisition dont c'est le premier
sujet c'est l'aggravation de la position
dominante de google
le second sujet c'est l'exploitation
finalement de cette position dominante
et les éventuels les abus à travers la
commercialisation de données qui sont
des données extraordinairement sensible
puisqu'il s'agit ni plus ni moins en
france et à la faveur du droit européen
que des données de santé de l'est de
santé qui sont qualifiés comme tel
puisque extrêmement sensible puisque
résultant d'une combinaison du poids de
l'âge de la taille des individus donc la
question c'est dans quelles mesures
devraient nous devrions nous pardonne et
moi nous contenter des promesses de
google qui semble promettre de ne pas
exploiter exactement les données qui est
finalement son et font le sel de cette
acquisition alors l'opération a été un
peu suspendue au bon vouloir en tout cas
à ce que va dire bruxelles qu on
attendre de cette décision et qu'elle
est vraiment la marge de manoeuvre de
bruxelles dans cette opération
je pense qu'il ya une crainte justifiée
de la part du régulateur européen qui
est en droit d'attendre de la part de
google que les données de santé soient
extraordinairement encadré que
l'hébergement de ces données soit
également certifié en tout cas en france
c'est ce que réclame le ministère de la
santé pour toute personne et notamment
google qui n'est pas un entrepreneur
différents et qui ne se doit pas se
soustraire aux règles du droit français
donc je pense que ce qu'on m'a demandé
c'est une grande vigilance et des
réponses de la part de google alors une
grande vigilance
concrètement comment ça se passait à
google rachète effectivement hafid bits
en tout cas ça va se concrétiser ou se
matérialiser par des réserves des
questions qu'on va poser à google de la
part du régulateur européen et google
devra apporter des réponses ses réponses
a peut être notamment de ne pas
commercialiser ces données cela peut
être de ne pas les commercialiser dans
certaines circonstances
ça peut être aussi ce qui me paraît
quelque part un peu dangereux c'est de
laisser soi-disant le consommateur le
choix de d'exploiter lui-même ses
données et en fait on prétend en réalité
responsabilité les consommateurs qui en
réalité ne l'est pas tout à fait
pourquoi il n'est pas tout à fait parce
qu'en réalité est-ce qu'on est
réellement mettre des ces données
lorsqu'on réalise des choix est-ce qu'on
valide exactement les conditions
générales
lorsqu'on appuie sur un bouton qui nous
permet d'accéder à un service est ce que
notre consentement
n'est-il pas vicié à travers le parc aux
utilisateurs des géants du numérique
tout cela paraît assez artificiel en
fait cette histoire cette opération de
rachat de par google de file vite ça met
juste en lumière quoi aujourd'hui le
consommateur est un peu en danger quand
il met ses données sur internet et ça
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que le
consommateur ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ils acceptent de laisser je dirais
aux géants du numérique et a fortiori
google le soin de disposer de ses
propres données dans une visée
commerciale puisque google n'est pas une
entreprise philanthropique
la question c'est de savoir jusqu'où on
va aller dans l'exploitation de ces
données sensibles et je crois savoir en
tout cas en france qu'il est une
réglementation très stricte qui
s'applique et que google de par sa
position dominante
il peut faire naître certaines craintes
en tout cas vis-à-vis des régimes dits
régulateur qui essaient leur rôle et
c'est leur droit le plus leurs prises le
plus strict pardonnez-moi sont en sont
en droit de questionner google c'est
vrai que dubuc merci d'avoir répondu
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste des nouvelles
technologies merci